j d vance republican senate candidate
who joins me now jd for some of us
a lot of republicans uh talk
too much about uh you know lowering
sales tax rates
in the cocktail bar of the titanic you
seem to be a bit more
urgent about some of the big picture
questions
yeah that's exactly right mark and
thanks for having me on and if folks are
interested please go to jdvance.com to
learn more about our campaign
i mean look i i think we're facing an
existential crisis in this country where
you have
the leadership of the country that
really doesn't seem to care about the
country or the people who live in it
they
are undercutting our wages through mass
immigration they're shipping a lot of
our manufacturing base off to china
allowing the chinese to build their
middle class
on the backs of ours and they're
increasingly unwilling to even reckon
with their own failure and so if you're
a normal guy
looking at your country going to hell
and you complain about it they call you
a racist or a bigot or a xenophobe or
maybe just a garden-variety idiot
and i think somebody needs to step up
and say look this is not okay it's not
okay to plunder this country their
our grandparents and our parents built
it's also not okay to
shoot us down to censor us on our big
tech platforms every time that we want
to complain about it
and both of those things are happening
the economic war against the middle
class
the cultural war against traditional
american values and i think they're very
related what what
does the right uh get by just kind of
going along because we we've got a left
that openly wants to get there
to floor it pedal to the metal and go
all the way with this stuff
and we've got the right that uh too
often gives the impression that it's
happy to follow after them
as long as they're just in second gear
third gear and uh
and and dialing it back a bit
yeah that's exactly right and i think
the big reason is that the right is
really terrified of power i think the
left is enthusiastic about using power
the right is terrified of power so just
take one example right the big tech
companies
which effectively control the flow of
information in our society now you
cannot speak your mind
as a conservative without fear of
getting censored by facebook
twitter apple whoever else well if you
try to do something when i say we should
be doing something about big tech
breaking up their monopolies making
their business model which effectively
just
allows them to steal data from us making
that business model
illegal or unacceptable what people
always say is well these are private
companies we can't do anything about
them well first of all
that's total bs they're not private
companies they've been given special
privileges by the government for decades
and on the other hand
what do we care more about the interests
of multinational companies that hate
this country
or the first amendment i care more about
the first amendment
no and and what's ridiculous about that
argument is that these uh
these companies are already bigger than
most nations on earth
and the the few nations uh they're not
bigger than
such as china they're entering into a
malign alliance with
and yet the right spends its time having
these sort of college dorm room
abstract discussions about the issue
yeah that's exactly right you know
google right now is actively conspiring
with and working with the chinese
government they've actually been very
open about this fact at the same time
the 29 year old woke idiots who work at
google refused to allow google to enter
into contracts with the us department of
defense
i mean this country this company is not
a national company anymore
it's not actually invested in the nation
that allowed it to become so wealthy and
so powerful
why do we keep on giving it special
privileges and you're exactly right
i'm just not okay with this anymore i
want my kids to grow up in a good
country
not a terrible one if we wanted one if i
want my kids to grow up in a good
country
we've actually got to push back against
the institutions that are that are
taking from it
quick final question uh jd the trump era
trump managed to smash through he was a
big enough personality he could talk
about some of these things
and at least five years ago get elected
on them what we haven't seen is whether
anybody else can actually get elected on
trumpian type big picture themes do you
think you can do it
yeah i think that i can and i think
you're exactly right you know i
obviously didn't fully appreciate the
president's appeal in 2016.
but i find it hilarious people who are
surprised that i think the way that i do
given
i've been going on tucker carlson's show
for three years talking about these
themes i clearly
believe and care about this stuff and
have for a long time
but i think other candidates can win on
some of these themes because this is
where the voters are
so many people think that trump was all
about personality i don't think they
give the president
or the broader movement enough credit
because it's not just about personality
it's about the ideas it's about breaking
up big tech
it's about preventing the destruction of
our manufacturing base
uh and shipping it off to china it's
about real things
and i think that if other folks are
willing to run on those real things and
not just
you know dns or excuse me rnc talking
points
then we actually have a real chance to
win this election and actually take the
country back
fabulous way to end uh run on real
things and not on republican talking
points
uh we'll watch this senate race with
interest thank you very much for joining
us tonight jd
vance thank you hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else